i've never paid for a date wow like a
you
um i would never even offer because it's
not a thing i've been taught so i guess
i've always just been brought up
like trying to best like men and women
as equals
yeah but you still you you still you're
still the head of the household so
if if me and you would share a house i
wouldn't be there at the house you
wouldn't
huh you wouldn't think that well no of
[Music]
course
i'm scared hi
hello hello hello hey
how you doing i'm good how are you good
my name's guy what's your name i'm tiana
tiana nice to meet you nice to meet you
a bit nervous
i am shaking and stuff
do you find me attractive yeah you're
cute
you're not my type dad uh-huh i've never
been with white guys so okay
um cute i never understand that because
i don't think i'm cute
i think it's your hair your hair doesn't
really matter yeah oh okay
yeah well yeah yeah yeah no i find it
attractive
yeah definitely that's good to know cool
have you
um dated a black woman before i i mean
the area i live in is very white
so you've got a so it's kind of almost
hard to find other people
of different ethnicities so what is your
preference like what have you
that commonly gone for
usually blonde tanned blue eyes
blue green interesting what about
yourself
mine have been tall dark and handsome
and i've recently just discovered that
when white girls say it it's white tall
but dark tanned i thought they were
talking about black guys
oh i see yeah because we say tall dark
and handsome but we mean black yeah yeah
yeah
yeah what's the best date you've ever
been on i don't really go on dates
because i think men are scary
um i think men are mad and
yeah okay am i scary and mad no you're
very nice i like your energy
could you oh my gosh not a funny joke
are you also interested in women when
you date my i've been with a girl there
okay like ages ago like when i was young
i would marry a man but finding the
right guy
finding the one that's not too crazy my
type of crazy yeah i understand
what's been your best date hmm
i don't know i once went on this date to
that um
cocktail crazy golf course yeah you can
have a great laugh and you have all the
like these
sugary cocktails with like sweets and
stuff do you know she's she's
it depends like if we're both working i
maybe expect her to our
offer or and then we might split but if
they're like
maybe not earning a lot of money or
don't have a job then i would always
just pay
okay sorry so you said that you expect
her to offer
if she's working and she has money
herself so you don't believe in looking
after her
huh of course i believe in looking after
women so then what do you pay on the
first date
i probably would because the first day
you should like it's like a universal
law to pay out of here yeah no okay i
usually no
i'm talking maybe like second third date
down yeah then i expect them so
i was referring to that date in
particular okay
i did pay yeah first dates usually i'd
pay
yeah it depends on the situation it
completely depends on the situation if
she offers
it's like i'll probably negotiate but
then i'll pay the first date but then as
it goes
negotiate with her huh no no no i'll be
like look i'll pay for the first time
and then maybe like down the line
yeah but first second date okay
first and second and third and fourth if
you want to
okay
okay i've never paid for a date wow like
a you
um i would never even offer because it's
not a thing i've been taught so i guess
i've always just been brought up
like trying to best like men and women
as equals
yeah but you still you still you're
still the head of the household so
if if me and you would share a house i
wouldn't be the head of the house you
wouldn't
huh you wouldn't think that well no of
course so would
like things be like 50 50. yeah
oh my god yeah what did you find that
weird to get your head around
do you think that's bad or good i
personally wouldn't want that
a bit of a alpha put it that way yeah
but it doesn't have any effect on like
it's just the world treat woman would
maybe be a slightly different
the way you would imagine a bloke too
so how many sexual partners do you have
do i have currently yeah have you like
had
had yeah i'll have to um
i don't know around 15 20.
it's not in the hundreds so that's yeah
yeah yeah
this was a question i was thinking about
last week i was like
no but you asked the lady back yeah yeah
yeah
i have had eight okay okay
i'm 27 so nobody judge me
blokes have yeah and have sex with loads
of girls yeah doesn't mean a girl can't
so i have no judgment and how
ever many yeah but you'd be surprised
like when that conversation
comes up a lot of people do judge women
yeah they're even having like three and
i'm like are you crazy
yeah i know but i'm saying i don't so i
know someone who has 300
wow where did you find the time what is
your credit score
i wouldn't be able to tell you okay do
you own your house i rent it and you
haven't checked your credit score no
oh gosh that's crazy i shouldn't mind
that all the time
i mean you're young i'm not very
materialistic
i'm much more experienced so like if i
can gather get like a
great memory out of spending money with
my friends and having fun with them i'll
value that and way more than a
500 pound jacket well i wouldn't say i'm
materialistic i like nice things
but i would pick a
a holiday to barley over a jacket any
day like that's me
um what do you think about marriage
because i know from a lot of
conversations nowadays
it's a weird one because it's originally
comes from religion which i'm not very
religious
um and then obviously there's a lot of
tax benefits and
financial benefits related to marriage
now which i think that's what most
people
do it for i'm a christian so i would
definitely like have to
not have to get married back i
definitely want to get married but yeah
i have
i'm not religious like i always tell
people i'm not really just like i have a
relationship with god which is
like completely different because
religion is rules and stuff whereas
i know god so yeah yeah i talk to god
that's my that's my g yeah um
so that is very important for me as part
of my beliefs
okay so are you a tory
yes but my political views are like i
try and keep away from that
if a topic is gonna specifically piss
someone off
why would i bring that up and why would
i try and convince them
that my view is better than theirs and
it's just gonna lead to a big argument
so
say you voted for for the tories yes
okay
great uh-huh i'm guessing your labor
and labor uh-huh so do you like agree
with like everything that boris has done
not everything no but no one's perfect i
get it but
like there's a lot of pressure on him
right now okay so what are the things
that you've agreed with like
that like he's done i think he's done
the vaccinations very well
do you think so i mean we're pretty much
the best in the world
most people have been vaccinated so i
think we've done a pretty look at europe
okay okay okay i mean i hate talking
about politics because
oh but you have to though you can't
avoid it i'm not gonna kick up a huge
fuss
if labour come into power and i have to
pay like it's
it doesn't faze me the tories have done
a lot of things that have affected a lot
of people's lives like people like
children have starved like
are you trying to say i like i don't
want to kick up a fast like it has to be
it's people's lives that have been
affected but
people's lives are always going to be
affected any decision so even if labour
come into power it's not like they're
going to make
no errors at all yeah but the rich will
still be rich and
the poor will be benefited from it
whereas tories
everything they've done has only
benefited the rich people
okay should we leave this one here no
no because it's an important
conversation
would you like to go on another date
you can go first ladies first no don't
make me go first
okay i am gonna say no because i think
there's certain things that make us
really really different and like i said
i don't like wasting time at
all you have your political views which
is completely fine but they just don't
work for me
um i would have to be with someone who
is a christian
um and values marriage as well like
before they meet me
so those are like my three big things
and that's the reason for this date
fair enough i'm always up for like
just meeting new people and
experimenting and seeing things work but
you know
um that was really awkward but i think i
now know how i can approach
like dates because i think getting to
the point is just so much easier for me
like
i don't want to waste anyone's time i
think i probably would have accepted
that he was a tory but the fact that he
didn't want to talk about it and express
his
opinions and like stand strong in them i
just like
wait if you're going to be a tory do
your chest i didn't know what to expect
at all
um it was fun maybe i'd do it again
an experience that's for sure are you
disappointed when she said no
no we also explored an anal pleasure
because the penis actually corresponds
um to
clitoris in women and so if men only go
for penile pleasure
that's like a woman only having literal
orgasm orgasms
so we involved the prostate and we
involved the anus as well that was
completely new for him